hey everyone Shazam was one of the
bigger trailers revealed at comic-con
this year and even though the footage
focus mainly on introducing us to the
hero Billy Batson and how he transforms
into the adult Zachary Levi Shazam if
you pay close attention this trailer
also dropped some interesting info about
the villain side of this movie so not
just mark Strong's character but also
some more subtle details that went to
Lex Luthor and how this how this whole
movie could set up the future of the DCE
you will get to say but first welcome to
New York circus news it's our deep dive
into all the biggest stories this week
so we're also gonna talk about Star Wars
Episode nine some details about
spider-man into the spider verse deleted
scene from ant-man the wasp and the
upcoming reboot of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer by Joss Whedon monster in the end
the team or Sam basher and Maude Garrett
welcome back how was Comic Con I'm
exhausted
I got a stomach flu as soon as I got
there oh yeah I was not a good and Sam
didn't have the best time that's true
last week I kind of made it seem like I
was like missing out like you guys left
behind I totally didn't mean for that
happened they didn't leave me behind our
us our own race so we didn't have an
invite to it that's how it works at
Comic actually I got a run I'm so sorry
I knew there was an invite there I knew
there is a plus-one somewhere that I
could have got no it's all good I was
happy to work here and now we have all
the comic-con trailers on our channel go
check them out if you haven't already
but we're gonna get started right now
with a Shazam and the trailer it's our
top story and the clues this trailer
gave us about the bad guys in this movie
are very subtle but we found them now
same already did a big breakdown
pointing out the many mini mini-me
Easter eggs to the DCU
thank you Sam comics go watch that
trailer breakdown it's awesome and one
of those details was a villain unveiled
in this movie dr. sivana
he's played by Mark Strong and Sam you
know that you pointed out that blue
twinkle in his eye and that actually
allows him to see and understand magic
that's all around us and Sam explained
it's connected to the character black
Adam who
now black Adam is the classic faux-fur
Shazam he currently actually has Dwayne
the rock Johnson attached to play him
though it sounds like he probably won't
appear yet in this movie maybe not even
a cameo but he will probably get his own
movie in the future too well this got
money and Dan he's gonna be on a
post-credits scene yeah that's probably
a good guess
for sure the Savannah actually gets that
I when he opens the tomb of Black Adam
and he gets half blinded by his magical
lightning and his comic comic origin is
that he's an evil scientist who's just
trying to save his family kind of a
doctor Friese type thing and also how
cyborg was made yeah now actually this
movie version played by strong also
encountered the wizard when he was a kid
that kind of changed his backstory but
unlike Billy Batson he was rejected from
receiving powers so ever since Savannah
has spent his whole life searching for a
way to gain the abilities that Billy now
possesses and a desire to live up to
some expectations of a domineering
father so that's kind of what we're
gonna be looking at he's just another
white man that's been rejected that's a
hey
yeah buddy the more he uses is weird oh
I hear he's got an eye though and the
more he uses it the more sick he get
that actually covers Savannah but
there's also a reference to the villains
of the broader DC EU now the bedroom of
Freddie Freeman is full of collectibles
memorabilia for other DC heroes but
hanging on his wall is a Daily Planet
newspaper with the headline Superman is
back it's referring to Superman's return
and Justice League but their sub
headlines if you look very closely at
this newspaper that say Amazon woman and
the Batman help combat Lex Luthor plans
and on the lower left you can see alien
attack on the world with the text
underneath saying the top suspect as a
worldwide search begins for those
responsible specialists say early signs
point to Lex Luthor and his associates
so it's interesting that Lex Luthor is
being blamed for stepping most attacks
though Luthor's seem pretty vocal about
the coming invasion at the end of Batman
V Superman and there was that deleted
scene remember in which she was seen
communicating with Steppenwolf on the
Kryptonian ship and
Lex Luthor's associates that could refer
to the Legion of Doom which was kind of
hinted at in the post-credits scene of
Justice League remember with Lex
breaking out of jail and he met with Joe
Manganiello it's Deathstroke and he's
asked I asked him shouldn't we get a
league of our own and there has been
some more later updates with the new
head of DC films Walter Hamada
he's indicated that plans to expand the
DCU in Legion of Doom or the injustice
leagues and we're saying it could be
that might not go in that exact
direction yet there's they're kind of
putting on the back burner at least of a
super interconnected Cinematic Universe
maybe they're waiting to see how these
next couple movies do before they nail
anything down but Justice League may not
have been as usually successful as a the
team-up franchise launch pad that we all
kind of wanted it to be and definitely
DC wanted to be but if Shazam or Aquaman
end up being the reset that they need do
you think DC should resume this plan for
a DC Legion of Doom I have a theory
theory they are already still laying the
groundwork for leading doom and if the
actors that they've got but everybody
else like Joe Manganiello I'm thinking
picture it with me it's so cool it's
literally after the scene the cutscene
that we saw all the the after credits
scene with Deathstroke and Lex talking
on the ship and you know he's like are
you you want to do this and he's like do
it I'll do it I've liked Luthor many
Deathstrike shakes his head
I've got this to do now I'm in I want
more Manganiello what mansion on my ello
if you know what I'm saying ello ello
hey yeah I think it speaks all of our
thoughts but I also I think that in the
origin from Shazam's comic it's somewhat
breakdown I talk about it a lot like you
said Black Adam and Savannah are pretty
intertwined and I think a good way of
kicking off like future plans is to have
a post-credits scene with Black Adam so
yeah Black Adam there we see Black Manta
and the Aquaman trailer and he looks
awesome and I've heard that the actor
I've not seen him in other pieces but
like I've heard that he's very good so
I'm very excited for that and clearly
he's probably gonna live out of this
movie he's gonna make it through cuz
Orme patrick Wilson's character is like
the main antagonist so you have Black
Manta yeah Black Adam you have
Deathstroke and you know Chi
is gonna be the main antagonist and one
of them in 1984 or if that's the
official title we're running with right
now
that plus if you want to add Lex in
there just for from comic accuracy
that's about everybody and then if you
want to beat the Green Lantern movie
throw Sinestro in there and then throw a
flash villain like Gorilla Grodd or like
a Captain Cold the Legion of Doom rock
up and then sua Suicide Squad rock up
and they're like oh oh what right well
Suicide Squad has to be good guys even
though they're our guys right there
empty heroes rather than villain it's it
is a contractual agreement you know and
the threat of death with the bomb in the
back of the brain yeah bet they have
kids there's some of them right well
yeah that was some it has kids real like
shut that Suns got kids I mean yeah I
mean I get why they may be kind of
hesitant right now to say oh we're gonna
be pursuing this like Justice League to
and injustice and there may be waiting
to see they're hedging their bets right
I get that but like yeah like just do it
the right way take your time with it the
way that you know rather than Suicide
Squad have this is all their first
movies and you have to introduce all of
them in one movie they're at a time that
they're panicking because they are so
many years behind I mean I mean came out
see well they don't have to be putting
them out at the same time Avengers is
going night night in about a year and
then see also they've kind of not I
don't like saying a franchise has been
exhausted but I think the reason why
Mission Impossible is going so
gangbusters at the moment it's cuz it is
so refreshing it's a different type of
movie and I think it's catering to a
more intelligent audience and I don't
insult anyone but I think that we have
seen sort of DC leaning - explosion
bangbang good you know and I think that
we need to treat the comic-book audience
with more intelligence well I think that
if you look at the difference between
Mission Impossible which you know we saw
it it's really good
the Chris McQuarrie that director really
understands the tone of that and it's
the clear partnership between him and
Tom Cruise and they they know exactly
what kind of movie they want to make
there's really no questions or like
experimentation that they have to like
try tonally speaking whereas like
unfortunately the DCE you just hasn't
had like a huge smash hit yet of like
yes is the exact one a woman was
fantastic but like aside from doing an
origin movie you know I am sure
Aquaman and maybe she's an Apollo and
some of those footsteps these team-up
movies haven't had a good like test
example this is what we want to try to
do every time can we have a quick way in
obviously we've seen the two trailers
now for Aquaman and Shazam what did you
guys think and which one did you prefer
I think Shazam but it's the it's a
teaser and they just got done getting
the footage loaded on the computers to
edit so it's like it what we got
visually is why like visuals wise it was
I was very happy with it and I thought
it was really cool yeah but Aquaman
somebody described this way but I'll
just say it again it felt like the
invention of it inventiveness of
guardians of the galaxy when we saw well
like when they go underwater you're like
oh we're gonna see a whole world and
there's like a cool energy to the
trailer into the world that James Bond's
is building and he has already built and
I wanna I want to explore that I'm
excited to explore that when Justice
League came out I was like what are we
gonna do and punch a guy with horns and
it's like we it doesn't matter with this
I'm like no this is their stakes there's
family and we get to see Jason like he's
gonna mature throughout the movie or
Arthur his character's name I'm excited
for that also Shazam it's big but with
like like everyone said it's big but
with superpowers
great yeah I wanted a big sequel now we
got it we said we didn't get much of
that maybe because it was just edited
one thing we did get from Shazam is torn
yeah it's fun yeah and it's okay see
it's okay
everybody you don't need to be super
serious yeah between the two of them I
would say I agree Shazam definitely had
a clearer tone it was probably most
excited to see the story and see these
characters I think at the end of the day
I have like a feeling that Aquaman might
be a more entertaining experienced only
because the directors just a bit more
experienced I think both David of
Samberg and James Wan are amazing
director interesting that they're both
horror but James Wan is just someone
who's like guided several different
fretless the Saw franchise the conjuring
franchise this guy knows like how to
like build a universe and he's guided
Davidov Sandberg he has a career because
of James Wan so absolutely
together James what did Fast and Furious
thank you thank you the most successful
Fast & Furious movie of the franchise as
well I'm a little worried about the
amount of CGI that we have for Aquaman
obviously that was to be expected
because you have a practical set
underwater would be very very tense a
lot of hair yeah you know what was the
the Lucas on movie of valerian yeah
in slide valerian vibes that's only
because they are world-building with the
computers and I'm but I agreed James Wan
is fantastic I also have at one of my
very good friends who is the second or
third ID on the set there and I've had
some stories that good or bad
um it's not gonna make me like Jason
Momoa as Aquaman is my why he's like a
surfer boy I'm excited no comment but ya
know Tom Cruise when it comes to doing
his own stunts and wanting to be on set
at all times and being professional in
the water I will say yeah I think those
of you follow me on Twitter know that I
went on a huge rant about CGI this week
at about criticisms of CGI in general
but I'm just a more of a defender on
that side of things where where III
where all I go into all movies with beer
goggles I feel like where I'm just like
hey and I'm and I'm less like particular
about CGI but I'm sure if I was a VFX
artist I might see the the seams in
between my thing is it sometimes just
become a barrier between relating to a
personal place ready play one I don't
know what they did but it was amazing we
had such a oh my goodness like it was so
much CGI but I was there I was with it I
was feeling it but there are some times
like in Justice League we're just really
detached for me because it was really
depending on the CGI so who knows who
knows actually here's a fun pitch well
you know everyone was like Dory flashes
like the spider-man for DC don't worry
every was gonna like him and I was fine
with them like I didn't hate him I in
any way I was just fine like nothing he
didn't cyborg I actually enjoyed more
than flash but what if Shazam was that
for them it's just like yeah no one
really knows what to do with Shazam it's
like no it's like exactly what you
wanted when you were kid it's you want
to be a superhero and he can literally
say it with one word isn't that such a
bad pitch for a character yeah I am
well I many times have you said it in
the mirror Sam yes
testing or a rainy day I might say it
more often than normal well I just hope
at the end of the day DC and Warner kind
of I want to see them blaze their own
Trail I think that we keep looking at
what Kevin Feige has done for morale
as the rule and it's really the
exception of the rule it's worked out
great for them but it doesn't
necessarily have to work for every
studio we don't have to see big team of
franchises work for every studio give it
pass but let us know what you think
about Lex Luthor coming back in do you
want to see it Legion of Doom movie and
do you want to see DC continue in this
path of an expanded universe unless no
the comments below but for now let us
move on to this week's trivia question
okay here we go the director of Shazam
recently revealed that the trailer
includes a reference to one other non DC
EU superhero who has appeared both in
comics and on the big screen who was
that
superhero okay all of our answers are in
the trivia question bucket here now
later in the show we will reveal the
answer to the trivia question as decided
by our judges and the winner will get to
do our sign off goodbyes to the end of
the video meanwhile the loser will
actually have to perform a brand new
punishment do it anymore
no it's gonna be good for all of us
hopefully you guys loved it oh it's
gonna be fine it's going super fun a
very very excited but yes the ground at
the end denoted it you get to experience
what a punch from Luke Cage feels like
alright everybody let's move on to some
breaking news that actually dropped in
the past few hours Star Wars Episode
nine director JJ Abrams announced that
Leia Organa story arc will be completed
using unseen footage probably deleted
scenes or b-roll shots of Carrie Fisher
from the force awakens
so here's Abrams full statement it's not
that long we desperately loved Carrie
Fisher finding a truly satisfying
conclusion to the Skywalker saga without
her eluded us we we were never going to
recast or use a CG character with the
support and blessing from her daughter
Billie we have found a way to honor
Carrie's legacy and role as leigh-anne
episode 9 by using unseen footage that
we shot together in episode 7 so that
sounds good and it was announced that
actually Mark Hamill will return perhaps
as a force ghost after in some vision
and he's joining me Anthony Daniels and
Billy Dee
who we already knew about so it sounds
good right it's probably most tasteful
way to honor her legacy but tickets I
want to see that because you know it's
all about those major carrier just
having their last hurrah and done in a
respectful way we had this with
obviously Han Solo in Episode seven and
then it was Mark Hamill's turn in
Episode eight and now it'll be layers
turn an episode no you're wrong because
we've talked before about how should
they do it should it be something in the
opening crawl that kind of explains
should have open on her funeral or
something like that but I think using
footage but not in a way that they
didn't like rogue one with the Tarkin
and yeah exactly that might seem a
little weird with someone who's just
passed ways to reason ingredient yeah
all right well let's move on to some
other news that came out another update
that actually came out from Comic Con
this week or last week rather from the
upcoming Spider Man into the spider
first movie the animated movie starring
Miles Morales now attendees were
actually shown an exclusive clip that
revealed three new incarnations of the
Spider Man with some exciting voice
actors first off there's spider-man noir
he's voiced by Nicolas Cage if he's a
gloomy hero who appears in black and
white and he has a dramatic wind blowing
around him they asked him like where's
that wind coming from we're in a
basement we don't have footage
fortunately it will be coming out soon
but then there's also penny Parker she's
a teenage girl with a robot named like
SP - - dr spider and she's voiced by
Kimiko Glenn she plays so-so and orange
is the new black if you want to show and
they have performance I heard it was
just say no
and there's spider ham it's not the one
fit in my left ear his ham ham ham ham
is hams a word for what do you call it a
ham do you know you know spider-ham
spider-ham I'm skipping past the point
here it's an anthropomorphic pig with
superpowers is voiced by comedian John
Mulaney he was a spider that has been by
a radioactive pig but I mean is this a
take-off the Simpsons know he'd been
around longer he'd been around longer
but he better sing that song mine or him
finer ham spider pig can't can you swing
from a whip no he can't cuz he's a pig
look how he is spider pig we now owe
$300,000 in two blocks I wasn't even in
key well another update from this week
ant-man in the wasp director Peyton Reed
revealed one of the deleted scene
concepts from the movie and boy did we
miss out on a fun fun cameo okay so
here's what was gonna happen Lewis he
you know as he repeats his amazing recap
gag that we saw in the movie where
Michael Pina voices yeah now originally
Reed said that part of his story time
was for Lewis to recap the airport
battle from Captain America Civil War
and the part where life cap and ant-man
team up said that Lewis is gonna
embellish it with like Katherine ant-man
like he's a baseball and that they were
gonna reshoot parts of the scene with
some crazy fantastical visuals but
didn't happen right the filmmakers
scrapped the idea is saying that they
wanted ant-man the wasp be more of a
standalone world and they had already
reference the event but it would have
been so I stopped there really got it
sorry much strategy script it was like
drink every time they bring up cat can
you do that point and you leaders
skipped Evangeline Lilly was fine but
like it would have been great yeah it
would have been good it didn't like they
didn't want to spend the money on the
effects to do a lot there so we got no
Chris Evans cameo but it just made me
think like what other there's other
great moments from the MCU that we need
Louise to recap right like that needs to
be its own short series before the movie
starts like have it as I like pay off
pay the money for the trailer you had an
Inhumans trailer you could pay to have
Louise be his little trailer play before
the movie star
yeah and it would be a little tough
before infinity war because it's some
little it's like explaining it
we don't know it's kind of yeah it's
left me on the wasp and you can't tell
if he made it or not you don't know no
no no four characters from that world
right the yeah yeah Pimm's in the van
dyne Saigon and the Lang is okay
well we don't have a kasi Lang whatever
his character's name Bobby kind of Karen
Olli yeah that guy hope he's okay he
likes magic trades all right another big
update from this week joss whedon
announced that he's developing a route
reboot of Buffy the Vampire Slayer
working with TV writer writer Monica
awooo sabrine and that this new Buffy
will star a black female lead now to
clarify Oh sue Breen said that this new
series won't be a reboot that resets the
timeline and erases or replaces the
original Buffy played by Sarah Michelle
Gellar and weed in this original series
but at this new Buffy will be more of a
revival set twenty years later when the
world seems a lot scarier and it's time
to meet a new Slayer so I'm curious what
kind of new scares do you think it was
sabrine could be referring to style for
2000 words do you think that we have
progressed enough in the you don't know
where the sentence is going to you use a
fun game makeup styles that we maybe
have more realistic vampires instead of
one a little bit yeah I mean it's
charming when you go back and watch it
just knowing that like you know the WB
didn't but yeah I would imagine they do
I mean I don't know you watch the air
over shows so what nope yep I do they're
a little leather we're gonna be promised
that I appreciate what you do up that he
jumps through yeah that's a pretty good
way of expanding
played a pixelated game from the 80s
called command & Conquer you'll notice
that that's one of the abilities that he
uses got a nerd onset everybody how did
a nerd get everybody
I watched angel I was I didn't watch
Buffy mainly cuz I do it but I've just
because of what we do now there's like a
lot of shows that we do watch for work
so it's a it's tough for me to pick up
an older show that has my season you
don't you still no bones Boreanaz argan
that show better no yeah I mean you were
spied in winter you like spike yeah yeah
I've attic states bond I want to be like
spike wanna be like spike hey he came
into the final season of Angel he was
great he was like go puppy became
basically when we didn't ever yes angel
so good I I would I'm on board with
checking out and also the effects budget
not just practical but visual effects
for like the flash show they're able to
pull off a lot of stuff for you like hey
you made a city ruled by Gorillaz make a
look okay so you could you could make
you could do some cool vampires called
Lee demons a pond with demons about this
is that a lot of people aren't really
happy about revisiting the Buffy French
I was already there saying but it was so
good the original we had so many great
seasons don't touch it just yet I think
the revival sort of a reboot is a great
idea yeah but what do you guys like do
you think we need more Buffy right now
no we don't need more of anything right
now if we don't watch it they'll get the
hint like they're making the Charmed and
I don't think anyone asks for more
Charmed
but the CW guy you covered the charms
come a premiere in this fall
I think Thursday's I think we could use
some more Buffy just if for no other
reason than it might bring people who
didn't watch the original series
some people were coming of age now who
might watch this show and be like oh no
there's this whole other series with
like this it's gonna be can't call it
Buffy Slayer Buffy
the Vampire Slayer I get the Vampire
Slayer's the you know the cross you bear
but copy buff or maybe she has a new
name it's her blank the vampire stuffy
the vampire Stephie yeah so let us know
what you want to see from this series I
think it's some exciting news and what
kind of type of horror elements that you
think 20:18 has the 1998 didn't have but
now it is time guys to move on toward
new rock stars news lightning where is
Alex budget you know I got some I got
some heat last week we're not doing a
lightning sound like totally I've been
saying Shazam quietly until something
came but nothing happened till a little
boy you start yeah it's like trying to
enter the CAPTCHA wrong too many time I
don't know which ones a monument I'm
sorry I don't Street it's for people I
don't know people can be so great oh and
a good questions this week I think I'm
gonna reuse some of these next week
because there's man you guys really
nailed it
yeah that's the same questions okay
we'll start with mott whitening that
jewels worth wants to know if you could
take any proper set piece from any movie
or TV show what would you take TV show
so it's lining around and I have to go
back to me like me like me like I'm
fighting fighting fighting fighting
whitening the crucible yeah
from witches from labyrinth Oh from
labyrinth okay yeah I wasn't thinking I
was letting it come to me my own throne
might be the one I'd go no it's not
supposed to be comfortable it's supposed
to wound you if you sit on it hard mind
you of them yes you can there's a
million rooms and they're swimming poor
you travel through time yeah other
dimensions to at Lackland underscore
pike and once
know if you could talk to any sea
creature what would it be and what would
you say otters
do they stay warm oh wait hold on did do
you like going ham oh good they hold
hands they don't flow away and drowned
it's really cute nails they put rocks in
their pocket they have a little skin
thing yes fold this kid they put rocks
in there their favorite they get
favorable cuz I roll them around their
body smooth the rock out yeah that rocks
Wow orders choo-choo train at sandy duck
wants to know what's your favorite
missing detail from your Dark Knight
breakdowns okay well yeah well you go
watch her Dark Knight series breakdowns
we haven't already we do one for Bethany
against our claimed arises a lot of time
on them and watch them please I'll give
you a detail that was not in the
breakdown I overlooked it it's from the
Dark Knight and I think it's really cool
the whole lower Wacker Drive chase
sequence when the Joker has the RPG they
did almost all of that with miniatures
they created a 1/3 of the size of the
real tumblr tumblr and a third the size
dump truck that it smashed into they lit
the they lit the miniature tunnel this
with the same under saturated lighting
that they have on lower Wacker Drive
they recreated it and it looks so
authentic when you see it they did some
amazing work with it I feel like a
dumb-dumb for not playing it out but
gree watch this movie and go there's
like a YouTube clip you can find where
they show the miniatures and everyone
else look up at Sandy duck and see if
that's a fake account and that Eric just
needed to cleanse his soul has been good
this person's only like rockstars tweets
[Laughter]
alright well thank you for tweeting us
your questions and we'll we'll hopefully
some of those most specific would be
great
you can specify any TV movie you've ever
seen ever
I don't like it it's also by the way a
bit tough what do you say like
recast ocean's 13 there's something we
have to think of like 13 to be your
favorite x-man
it's alright who should play the
Fantastic Four I'm like a lot of
pressure go one but thank you thank you
even if you don't narrow it down we just
love hearing from you guys let's take a
look at what we got in the pipeline well
you know it's we're still gonna spent
from this past week guys we did a lot of
content on us wow there's a lot of good
stuff to watching now on our Channel
then I'm sure you haven't watched a
whole of it mission impossible yeah well
we do have a video coming out on Mission
Possible follow up it's a great movie we
haven't really done a lot of Mission
Impossible coverage but like watching
this movie there's a lot of like little
subtle like design choices and
influences and the director Chris
McQuarrie has been like pretty candid
about like the different things that
influenced him in little details that he
snuck into different shots that there's
just a lot to break down here on why
it's a good movie so I think we're gonna
be doing a breakdown it's like it's some
theory videos from some of the trailers
we've done like Shazam and Godzilla king
of the monsters some theories that some
of you guys have messaged us and there's
I feel like there's probably more to
talk about there what kind of theories
do you get from Godzilla darboux are
they are they gonna come together into
one big monster yeah it's it's Power
Rangers and I and I rode and clapped you
there cuz that's there's a lot there
look I'll be honest I didn't know Titans
and kaiju monster verse history before
this trailer came out I had actually
seen I realized some of the stuff on TV
and my childhood but there is an
elaborate history and backstory to all
these kaijus all these are different
those weird twins that soothe mother I
hope they're in this movie I don't know
how mother fights bothers just got the
giant Martha it protects it's yeah it's
mothers on our side
you know the remind players like the
Mars player and the same actress who's
kind of doing the same thing in this
movie she might even have powers I have
a theory about that and in our trailer
breakdown she might have some kind of
telepathic abilities we don't know we'll
find out but yeah I keep an eye out for
those on the channel coming out in the
next week and again and go watch our
breakdowns but see now comes the time
for a 15-second shout out or
you just the 60 seconds to shut up plug
or Ram about anything one Sam
Thursday's 4:00 p.m. PST on twitch.tv
slash play noggin that's an OGG I n I
have a new show I do it's it's like you
got like nerd news got lifestyle stuff
you got convention coverage and you got
gaming we launched this week it exceeded
expectations and it was it was went
better than you could ever imagine you
can check out patreon until I get
involved with it but it's also free to
watch so just go to that twitch channel
4 p.m. Thursdays it's a blast hope to
see you there my clothing label what
launched was exceeded expectations as
well I'm not humble bro
blatantly bring it I'm shouting out did
Skyrim guys this game keeps giving I
played it for seven hours yesterday
which one Skyrim double one new one yes
the one well the one that they read kind
of like do you got to make look better
but there's not there's no like Elder
Scrolls this is still the game where you
can put in easily 300 hours and keep
exploring every part of it and I didn't
got lost and I loved it killed a few
blood dragons you're welcome it's fine
thanks Hank no big thing yeah well happy
welcome 15 seconds I watched Hannah
Gatsby's Netflix comedy special called
Nanette she's so funny she's an
Australian comedian she is in G from
Tasmania and she has some very very
interesting views it's it's it's a
comedy special unlike any that I've ever
seen so I highly recommend you watch it
you may not totally agree politically
with with some things she says because
she's Australian is really yeah yeah yes
and she's lesbian so she's kind of
talking about her story in a way that
not a lot of lesbian comics have so
definitely check it out and just a one
non controversial thing that you know
that I struck me that all that I'll drop
you with she did a really cool thing
about she joked about how people have
told her that as a comedian she should
not self-medicate and she should not
take care of herself because it'll like
limit her creativity and she got joked
about that she's an art history major
and she talked about how van Gogh people
said oh he didn't medicate right he was
crazy cut his ear off he actually
painted several portraits of people they
found out were his therapists so he was
taking care of himself and and many of
his floral paintings is a pretty
Euler plant that was ingested
medicinally that they later found out
allows human beings to see the color
yellow more vibrantly so there's an
argument to be made that he was such a
master of painting because he medicated
himself and because he took care of
himself so it's just some art history
stuff where I'm like that's very
interesting I the world creative people
and I think sometimes there's this idea
that you have to be broken to be a
creator
yeah can we throw that out yeah can we
throw that in the trash buddy and you
mind hey what are you wrecking a
brighter color yellow looks like he does
the sunflower you got the starry night
that's really cool that's so I'm gonna
watch that that's actually really cool
very good check it out at least watch a
couple minutes of it see see how if
you'd go to the doctor for a flu then
you should go to a therapist for your
burn and go to shop what.com oh yeah see
I plugged in Oh smack talk about it
whatever oh you go smack talk about I
trust didn't curse alright I jerk around
it I try to not say a swear bat shop
would know I go to the websites right
there yeah sorry definitely let's return
to our trivia question that we asked
earlier now
before I reveal what the answer is I
want to reveal our brand new punishment
for the person with the least correct
answer alright guys we are now if I have
to make out with Henry Cavill of shame
the way this works is the loser will
have to pull a task from this container
and each task is a movement or a gesture
that the loser must perform over and
over again during during our goodbyes
and we're gonna make an animated gif of
you doing it we're gonna blast it out on
social media to shame you for your
trivia experience the gif of shame and
will chance shame like in Game of
Thrones probably well you and hopefully
this catches on of what the question 40
not not one let's go the tough one
how many times they have me push-ups can
Zachary Levi do when he preps for Shazam
you wrote a number yeah
alright the director of Shazam recently
revealed that the trailer includes a
reference to one other non DC EU
superhero who has appeared both in
comics and on a big screen who is a
superhero and what it says spider
moaning why not right yeah Oh Shazam is
your joke write down never thought of
Shazam before nope until just now great
doesn't work that way
only works that way hey by the way guys
can you please stop sending me about
that um german word which means that i
have a mental disorder where i cannot
not do puns in foreign or something
where it's like you have to make a pun
in and jokes even at inappropriate times
hmm cool Eric Eric this is blade I got
it said the Bible what superheroes
naughty see you can it's only one of
those work miracles right yeah well the
answer is the comedian from Watchmen we
come up into conversation ever it
doesn't come in conversation it shows up
as the I guess the happy face DC Comics
no not DC it's a strike
Starfire does it count because she's
neither the DCU it's like saying that a
human can't play head because she's an
alien
mmm we gotta talk about that
okay well who as our judges yeah I'll
take it
sounds good okay so our judges have said
that Sam and I are equally wrong so
we're gonna rock-paper-scissors for it
ion shoot yeah Rock papers yeah ready
Rock Paper Scissors shoot
why wouldn't it be why wouldn't it be
model through our good-byes and same
we'll have to draw from the gif of shame
I have a task go on reenact the man's
face melting off from Raiders of the
Lost Ark slow motion become a human
candle yeah so Sam will melt and that
will be our gift of shame ESMOD desert
goodbyes did you like the Temple of Doom
harp repair I watched that too young
thank you so much for watching this
episode of new rock Sonya is actually to
be fair this looks like say I'm trying
to answer the funny
not much of a difference between these -
I want to thank our host our Eric Voss a
ta vas if you want to follow along
because he does constantly tweet from
new rock such as well Sam - ah he's
slowly melting away at samba
my name is Maude Garrett at Lourdes sure
comment down below tweet us at you rock
stars like a video share it around
subscribe Sam's actually moving the
table we love giving you deep dives and
digging into the stuff that you love so
Sam if you never see him again it's
because he died of shame thanks guys
take her places under the tape
all right yeah you're right this'll work
we'll see that you drew a good